[Instrumental music playing]
Ah
To the list of things
that make me sad,
I add each day
each day
The color goes.
This is the world:
Just gray and gray
and gray.
Longing is the same in both directions.
Look at the sky
and remember
Everything beautiful
lies both forwards and backwards.
Look at the sky
and remember.
That it’s good to be alive.
Ah ah ah
Overwriting the written constellations
I create my own new map
I trace my finger
along the lines.
I am the little blade of light
Blade of light
from the crack in the door.
I am the orange wedge
Of sun
Through your window.
This is the beginning
of the story we tell
again and again
It is the beginning
Who will listen?
of the story we tell
We are fragile
we are precious
we are fragile
We are fragile
we are precious
we are fragile
We are fragile
we are precious
Who will listen